est ce que ces gens sont des merdes
c'est la troisième fois que je me pose
la question les retours sur l'épisode 2
était trop stylé y en a même qui en
veulent
toutes les semaines nous pensons
regarder ça exceptionnel merci merci
c'est trop cool c'est trop cool moi
aussi je kiffe
j'adore lire vos commentaires et ses
avoirs aux avis sur telle et telle
question c'est hyper kg je rappelle le
principe pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas ce format c'est qu'en fait on va sur
ce brésil qui s'appelle amélie aso
suis-je le trou du cul on va traduire sa
part je suis une merde
en plus ça se passe au même endroit et
en gros c'est des gens qui racontent
leur histoire ils savent pas trop quoi à
6 cd merde ou soit s'ils ont mal agi ou
s'ils ont bien agi et des questions
éthiques qui se posent et nous moi
j'aime pas trop juger à la batte
mais là c'est le but donc c'est parti
pour ce nouvel épisode 2 est ce que ces
gens sont des merdes à rio alors c'est
le ceo du montage j'ai un truc à vous
dire mais en fait c'est pas moi qui
montre la vidéo
du coup je vous renvoie le alfie du
montage you alors on voulait juste vous
prévenir que le fonds vert qui arrive
n'est pas fou fou on a un peu merdé mais
ça s'arrangera peine quelques secondes
bon visionnage est-ce que je suis un
bâtard pour avoir refusé de faire plus
de plats à ma copine après qu'elles se
soient plaints de ma manière de cuisiner
assez incroyable ça ça incroyable voilà
c'est ça qu'on veut ça c'est fou ça
c'est fou j'en parlais ya pas longtemps
avec ma soeur de ça parce qu'il ya des
gens il faut en manger
genre tu peux pas critiquer parce
qu'après ils disent ok bah je fais pas
manger gros c'est parce que j'ai dit je
lis excusez moi je me suis emporté jolie
les choses se passent plutôt bien avec
ma copine c'est une meuf de 28 ans je
suis un mec de 26 ans
ça fait quatre ans qu'on est ensemble et
on vit tous les deux depuis deux ans
dernièrement il ya eu quelques tensions
pour ces faux je veux le bonheur de tout
le monde
on travaille tous les deux beaucoup donc
on est tous les deux un peu sur les
nerfs et d'humeur changeant notamment ma
copine qui a été sèche avec moi quelques
fois et a été vraiment de mauvaise
humeur
ce qui les embête ces derniers jours
c'est surtout ma cuisine c'est
généralement moi qui fais les petits
déjeuners qui prépare nos déjeuners et
les dîners donc tout mais en fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle prépare le goûter
littéralement à chaque fois je suis
derrière la cuisinière elle se plaint de
comment ça sent mauvais voilà du fait
que j'utilise des trucs qui sont sont
pas bons voilà que ça c'est un mauvais
goût et même et termine pas sa
nourriture
ça me rend ouf j'ai fait pas un chef
mais voilà je suis assez content de ma
cuisine et donc ça ne touche que m 10 à
quoi j'ai eu mes collègues qui ont goûté
mon déjeuner et ils m'ont dit que
c'était très bien je me dis que
peut-être qu'avec tout le stress qu'elle
en train de subir au travail et c'est
peut-être qu'elle a besoin d'un endroit
où être moi déverser sa frustration mais
j'étais un peu cassant ce matin lorsque
deux nouveaux essais pleins de
l'aublette que j'étais en train de nous
faire donc j'ai jeté les eaux à la
poubelle
je lui ai dit qu'elle peut faire
elle-même son [ __ ] de petit déjeuner
et cuisineraient plus pour elle si elle
continue à agir comme si elles étaient
gâtés à et on a fini par avoir une
dispute est trop tard et on est parti au
travail en étant énervés l'un contre
l'autre
finalement mathy copine n'est pas rentré
à la maison et sa soeur m'a appelé ou
comme on dit ça à escalader vite ma
copine est vener contre moi et sa soeur
pensé que j'étais un bâtard de réagir de
manière aussi mature en refusant de lui
cuisiner à partir de maintenant des
choses surtout sachant à quel point elle
travaille donc parfois n'a pas le temps
de faire ses propres troupes
je sais pas pourquoi ça a pris ces
proportions mais voilà je suis là chez
moi à me demander si je suis un bâtard
du fait d'avoir perdu mon sang-froid et
lui avoir dit que je ne cuisine ray plus
rien je pense juste que c'est injuste de
me dire tout ça à propos de ma cuisine
alors qu'elle n'a jamais fait avant et
que bah si elle n'aime pas elle peut
cuisiner elle aussi est ce que j'ai été
un bâtard
après il ya un update déjà avec ces
informations là c'est très difficile
pour nous de juger là parce que on ne
sait pas à quel point c'est difficile
est bonne
sachant que même si elle est mauvaise il
ya des manières de dire les choses et
effectivement il a raison si m
tu le laisses pas faire matin midi et
soir c'est d'accord sur le fait que bon
t'as pas le temps de le faire
cela arrange bien qu'elle fasse pour toi
c'est pas cool de dire à cette personne
à quel point c'est nul
tout le temps et de même pas finir le
truc enfin tu peux ne pas finir le truc
mais les dires c'est tellement nul que
je vais finir c'est pas génial c'est un
peu blessant treize mois j'ai
l'impression avec ces informations là
que c'est plutôt elle la bataille après
le fait de craquer jeter les oeufs et
tout à la poubelle
c'est un peu gamin est bon il a pris sur
lui pas mal de temps après ça se trouve
elle aussi à la pression elle pas mal de
temps dans ce cas là les deux sont
fautifs ne pas avoir partagé tout de
suite et communiquer tout de suite bon
j'ai reçu beaucoup trop de répondre pour
moi et la plupart pointent des choses
qui paraissent évidentes mais dont j'ai
même pas pensé avant vous mentionnez il
était très tard quand j'ai posté ça et
je voulais attendre le lendemain matin
pour lui parler j'ai raté un de ces
appels
donc je les rats un ton totalement
différent cette fois elle a été vraiment
à s'excuser
à propos de comment elle a agi et c est
qu elle n'a pas réalisé à quel point
c'était une vérité chc ces mots
apparemment jusqu'à ce qu'elle en parle
avec sa soeur apparemment quand sa soeur
l'a compris elle a même réagi en disant
genre vraiment tu as fait ce qu'il dit
ce que j'en pensais que c'était pas cool
que elle se sert de moi comme punching
ball et que je méritais pas ça elle a
été vraiment compréhensive et on a on
s'est mis d'accord pour en parler plutôt
que laisser le truc déborder voilà ok
donc maintenant revenons à ce que tout
le monde veut entendre ma copine est
rentré à la maison
[ __ ] incroyable je suis en train de
lire ce qui se passe c'est incroyable
quand on est rentré j'ai eu et j'ai prié
pour que m
décapite pas pour lui parler des
hormones parce que en gros il dit
peut-être que tu étais vénère à cause
des ormes et il dit sa réaction était
trop marrant parce que l a pas pensé à
ça elle non plus qu'on a on est la
pharmacie et on a acheté juste quelques
tests pour être sûr on en rentre à la
maison et ils sont positifs assez fou
j'ai des petits frissons dans le dos il
ya dix ans la vache je n'imaginais pas
que vous aviez raison à propos de ça je
me sens un peu bête ne pas y avoir pensé
j'avoue
du tout pensé mais ouais elle et elle
est enceinte et on est juste super
excitée évidemment elle a pleuré aussi
un petit peu c'est beau [ __ ] je
n'arrête pas d'y penser c'est fou edit
j'ai envoyé ce poste à ma copine et
remercie tout le monde d'avoir pointé la
raison évidente du truc est dit que vous
êtes tous invités à la baby shower folle
histoire folle histoire
non c'est pas du tout un assaut le gars
est cette meuf non plus c'est un très
beau coup qui sont extrêmement heureux
c'est tout ce qu'on leur souhaite
beaucoup d'amour
ce titre est ce que je suis une merde
parce que je fais semblant de dormir
toute la nuit pour voir si ma femme me
manque
ah là là on va se régaler ces deux
derniers mois
ma femme s'est beaucoup plainte de nos
chats elle dit que les chats la réveille
constamment et que l es frustré toute la
nuit que elle a besoin de se lever et
d'ouvrir la porte pour les chats parce
que sinon les chats n'a pas faire du
bruit ou le chat n'a pas de sauter sur
elle ça arriver au point où elle m'a
demandé de me débarrasser déjà jeudi
mais jamais vu ni entendu quoi que ce
soit ce truc là mais dit que c'est parce
que je dors toute la nuit quoi elle à
part été de me dire que l avait de moins
en moins de sommeil
et elle était de plus en plus agressive
en blâmant les chats pour son manque de
sommeil et que si je me débarrasse et
pas deux elle me quitterait un matin
c'est avant tout excité elle a dit
qu'elle s'est réveillée plusieurs fois
dans la nuit pour aider les chats elle a
précisé multitude de fois parce que
j'étais réveillé jusqu'à 4 heures du mat
et elle a dit que s élever à 1h du mat
pour ouvrir la porte et quelquefois
autour de 3 heures du mat
parce que ils violaient et sauter sur l
j'étais dans la chambre à coucher tout
le temps où elle dormait et je sais que
rien de tout cela n'est arrivé
les choses n'étaient pas logiques donc
j'ai décidé de faire un test trop
bizarre pourquoi de 8o c'est le mytho
j'ai attendu qu'elle dise qu'elle est
couché et j'ai mis les chats en dehors
de la chambre à coucher baisser la
luminosité mon téléphone et j'ai fait
semblant d'aller au lit j'étais juste là
allongé dans l'île toute la nuit très
ennuyé mais je suis clairement pendant
deux ans déjà prouesse va pas vous dire
je suis incapable de faire ça et vous le
saurez si vous regardez la vidéo qui
sort la semaine suivante puisque je
parle de sommeil est-ce que c'est du
teasing
oui pour être sûr je vais checkpoint
toutes les demi heures sur mon téléphone
via discorde j'ai écrit tous les sons
que mécha faisait un cha a sauté de
quelque chose et a fait un petit sont à
3h18 du matin et 1 s'est nourri avec
assez peu de bruit au niveau de la porte
de l'argent à coucher vers 4h45 du matin
en dehors de ça rien ne s'est passé à
peu près sûr que ma femme a dormi de
onze heures du soir à 9 heures du matin
et ce matin là elle a dit qu'elle s'est
réveillée au moins cette fois pour
ouvrir la porte et à cause de bruit de
chats et de chats qui sautait sur elle à
ce moment là c'était horrible de
quelqu'un qui te manque comme ça
ouvertement devant toi tu sais la vérité
fois il ya cette sensation cette émotion
est horrible en fait cessé au ris parce
qu'il ya plein de sentiments sont
mélangés déjà tu perds quelqu'un que tu
n en fait que tu estimes et c'est super
ça tu estimes tu perds une connexion
avec cette personne on prend pour un con
quand même donc ça s'est jamais agréable
le fait que tout ça s'effondre et puis
en fait je dis voilà tu te projettes
aussi tubes acier attend 6 est
personnellement sur ça elle peut mentir
sur quoi d'autre en fait à ce moment là
j'étais vénère parce que clairement elle
me mentait j'en pouvais plus les
mensonges et je veux juste balance à la
figure je vais dit smar en date famille
donc je dis je reste éveillé toute la
nuit pour vérifier les chats et tous et
il était même pas dans la chambre
l'année dernière j'ai tout noté donc tu
me ment est essayé de me convaincre de
me débarrasser de mes chats pourquoi à
ce stade l histoire et fiction juste
pourquoi soit cette personne je déteste
les chats c'est possible soit les jeux
allergique aux chats par exemple elles
n'osent pas le dire je sais pas je sais
pas c'est vraiment très bizarre quoi
était juste assise là on tremble un
petit peu en ayant l'air énervé
j'étais à s'élever et elle est partie
sans répondre elle revenu des heures
plus tard en mignot rang peu importe ce
que je disais et quand je vais demander
comment ça se faisait que j'étais le
méchant dans cette situation elle m'a
finalement dit que je la traiter comme
une enfant parce que j'ai menti à propos
du sommeil parce que j'étais resté
éveillé toute la nuit voir si elle
mentait ou pas et que faire des check
points sur dix cordes etc
c'était allé trop loin et que ça faisait
deux mois une merde obsessive ça rend
fou les gens qui font ça c'est les gens
qui retiennent que le dernier truc ici
j'ai fait ça en fait parce qu'il ya des
trucs avant on peut parler de la base du
truc eh ben dis je les fais parce
qu'elle menaçait de
de me quitter si je me débarrassais pas
de méchant donc je suis une merde
obsessive part dans les commentaires
tout le monde dit voilà te fais pas
avoir c'est un chiffre de manipulation
et c'est clairement ce n'est pas la
mauvaise personne et c'est évidemment
mais est-ce qu'on a la réponse sur les
chars et quelqu'un qui dit oui avec ces
changements comportement etc
peut-être qu'il faut les voir un
psychiatre ou quoi ou aller voir de
l'aide parce que c'est extrêmement chaud
vous savez que c'est extrêmement chaud
dans les commentaires et disent que ça
ressemble à un trouble qui s'appelle le
trouble donc c'est en anglais et non
chez citic pe 10 heures donc c'est le
trou de la personne et narcissique
c'est un soda personnes étaient dans
lequel un individu se manifeste par le
besoin excessif d'être admiré et par un
manque d'empathie le sujet narcissique
recherche une gratification en lui-même
et s'attache peu aux jeunes en des
autres et très focalisée sur ses
problèmes d'adéquation personnel de
puissance et de prestige
le trou de la personnalité narcissique
il est étroitement liée à l'égocentrisme
alors pour le manuel diagnostique et
statistique des troubles mentaux
le patient présente au moins 5 d un dôme
suivant le sujet un sens grandiose sa
propre importance
par exemple ils surestiment ses
réalisations et ses capacités s'attend à
être reconnu comme supérieur sans devoir
accompli quelque chose en rapport
ça pour l'instant c'est moi idéalise un
alter ego conçu comme objet principal de
ces discussions
ouais ça c'est cyrus mars est absorbée
par des fantasmes de succès illimité de
pouvoir de splendeur de beauté de
perfection ou d'amour idéal quand est ce
qu'on arrive aux 5 millions d'abonnés
s'énerve facilement quand on ne répond
pas à ses désirs ou à ses besoins marche
bien le micro là où par l'aap hutin
pense être spécial et unique et ne
pouvoir être admis ou compris que par
des institutions ou des gens spéciaux et
de haut niveau 1 ça j'avoue ça c'est
vraiment moi je pense pas être spécial
et unique
je le suis je le sais enfin excusez moi
mais le fait que vous m'écoutez là tout
de suite c'est en est la preuve
je pense que tout lui est dû satan sans
raison a bénéficié d'un traitement
particulièrement favorable est ce que
ces désirs soit automatiquement
satisfait que ça m'arrive de temps en
temps exploite l'autre dans les
relations interpersonnelles utilise
autrui pour parvenir à ses propres fins
mensonge chantage violence verbale sa
patronne ouais non masse mieux le pied
là tu veux que tu veux dormir ici ou pas
bahamas mieux le pied manque d'empathie
n'est pas disposée à reconnaître aux à
partager des sentiments et les besoins
d'autrui masse chez non tu vas pas
bouffer en fait j'ai désolé pendant ce
pas toi que je dis je suis désolé
envie souvent les autres ou croient que
les autres l'envi les à combien
d'abonnés à pully passes en neuf minutes
en cache des informations aux autres
pour arriver à ses fins car ça pour le
coup je le fais pas à tous les autres
oui mais ça notre épreuve d'attitude de
comportement arrogant et hautain please
non ça je suis bien au dessus de ça ok
alors blague à part
en quoi ça tombe sur nous alors pourquoi
on parle de la meuf de chalamov des
chats peuvent déjà mais pense que tout
lui est dû
donc c'est à dire se débarrasser des
chats machin et cache des informations
aux autres pour arriver à ses fins
manque d'empathie il est clairement la
personne avec qui elle est mc j'ai donc
elle exploite l'autre dans les relations
interpersonnelles donc changement son
chantage etc
mais j'ai pas le côté grandiose fantasme
de succès limité le fait d'être spécial
et c'est le besoin excessif et admirait
ça je le vois moins ça écrit qu'un dans
les commentaires qui dit moi j'irai
encore plus loin et je prendrai rendez
vous avec un spécialiste pour cela pas
des hallucinations à propos des chats
c'est peut-être qu'elle ment pas en fait
quelque chose d hallucinations ça serait
fou cendre c'est marrant parce que et un
autre commentaire qui dit la même chose
aussi avant de le lire j'ai une petite
pause la première lecture prenez un truc
qui vient à l'esprit c'est voilà c'est
mythos a dit n'importe quoi et c'est en
fait on la blâme ne pas avoir assez
d'empathie et on se retrouve à se rendre
compte que peut-être que nous on en a
pas assez parce que a peut-être qu'elle
a vraiment des hallucinations et que
c'est pas une menteuse en fait on après
supposer que c'était une mytho il faut
jamais présupposés ça qu'on devrait lui
poser la question genre est ce que tu
m'as menti ou est ce que tu entends
vraiment les chats quoi et donc la
personne qui a posté a répondu en disant
que c'est possible théoriquement mai
j'avais mentionné ce genre de problème
et elle avait un très bon sommeil
jusqu'à assez récemment et une autre
personne qui répond qu'elle a des
épisodes de paralyser du sommeil et qui
avait souvent le chien dans la chambre à
coucher
quelque chose qui ce qui arrive après si
on va plus loin dans le dénouement il y
en a aussi qui disent que sa réaction en
fait montre qu'elle n'a pas de problèmes
de sommeil que c'était juste du mytho
parce qu'elle est et vénère et ses mains
ça je trouve ça juge je trouve ça
difficile pour le coup de juger sur
cette réaction
en fait ils disent que si elle pensait
vraiment avoir vu les chars et l'aurait
genre elle se serait battu latuquois et
le fait que en fait se bat pas du tout
la tuque à se battre sur le fait qu'il
ait menti ça montre qu'elle sait en fait
la mito bastien s'assied dans tous les
cas la relation est assez mal sénat je
rappelle qu'elle faisait quand même un
ultimatum tu débarrasse des chats ou je
te quitte est-ce que je suis une merde
voir quitter le déjeuner avant que mon
ami arrive sans le prévenir
j'ai donc une femme de 32 ans avait un
déjeuner organisé avec un ami un homme
de 32 ans ce pote est toujours en retard
à tout et n'importe quoi imaginons que
c'est moi c'est mon brief être en retard
c'est ok cependant j'ai pour moi cette
époque tous les téléphones etc
on devrait pouvoir prévenir la personne
que voilà on arrive assez en retard un
rendez vous en dites ça à moi je le
faire je vais peut-être un peu trop
souvent d'ailleurs mais moi je préviens
toujours j'ai pris mon café à midi ce
qui était leur qu'on s'était donné je
m'assois la tave entouré des gens qui
sera dans un café c'est bondé à 12h30
mon ami toujours pareil j'ai reçu aucun
message donc je suis simplement levé et
je suis rentré chez moi à aucun moment
j'essayais de lui créer un message ou de
l'appeler voir où est ce qu'il en était
quoi ça chauffe déjà je comprends pas à
quoi je veux dire un peu nul hockey dont
il prévient pas c'est nul mais je dire
tu as ton téléphone aussi tu peux te
régaler envoyé un message pour le coup
assez legolas et légaux qui affecte
d'abord envoyé message le truc c'est que
je savais qu'il avait oublié notre
déjeuner et qu' il était juste
habituellement retard en fait mais j'en
avais marre de ça à 12h38 40 minutes
après notre heure de rendez vous je
reçois un message à part qui dit je suis
là où est ce que tu es j'ai répondu je
suis parti du principe que tu venais pas
du coup je rentrais chez moi et ensuite
j'ai refusé de rentrer au café pour le
déjeuner je sais que la communication
marche dans les deux sens mais
ce que je suis une merde mon mari pense
que j'aurais juste dû l'appeler puisque
je connais sa tendance à être en retard
quarté payne merde mais c'est pas ou
quoi
c'est totalement de sa faute à lui ce
qu'il est en retard et c'est tard elle a
pas être en retard il ya une règle qui
éclaire la une heure de rendez vous il
n'a pas respecté en ne prévenant pas
qu'il est en retard il se pointe le mec
avec 30 minutes de retard mais bonne
volonté ou ok c'est une merde par contre
juste partir sans le prévenir et ses bas
c'est descendre aussi bas que lui quoi
donc tes pattes est pas une merde mais
tu aurais pu faire mieux je me souviens
d'une fois où j'étais
ça va arriver un d'être très en retard
pour eux mêmes des tournages ou des
rendez vous etc et ça m'est arrivé qu'on
m'envoie un message en étant un messie
russe c'est trop tard en fait vient pas
tu peux faire demi tour je suis parti
c'est genre bah je peux vous dire que
voilà je n'ai pas reçu beaucoup de fois
ce message parce qu'en fait les moments
où j'ai reçu vraiment ça ça fait un truc
en moins ça a changé ma conception du
truc et je me suis vraiment c'est pas
possible quoi cyrus juste d'arriver en
retard au point où les gens te disent de
rentrer chez moi tu sais pas possible
voilà maintenant ça va beaucoup mieux
quand ce retard c maximum 10 15 minutes
et surtout je le suis beaucoup moins
qu'avant avant c'était systématique
maintenant c'est plus le cas est ce que
dans les commentaires ou même félicité
un petit peu et m'encourager sur cette
voie vous le ferez aussi pour tous les
gens qui partagent mon problème de
retard merci beaucoup
on vous remercie tous et tout merci au
dernier épisode je vous ai dit envoyer
vos histoires et c est en fait j'aurais
dû donner une adresse mail clairement à
ce que j'en ai reçu sur instagram armé
par match
trop compliqué en plus il ya certaines
personnes m ont écrit un livre est moins
écrit le livre me l'envoyer par appeler
flammarion on appelle flammarion vous
fait éditer
d'ailleurs ce matin en fait rire ce truc
de les gens m'envoient des livres que je
vous faire écouter la note vocale que
j'ai laissé à mon agente d'un bouquin
s'appelle des abonnés sont ils des
merdes et je sais que j'en comprends
toutes les histoires de mes abonnés et
jacques histoire singe a pu tenter à
leur injecte un qr code tu peux voter si
tu penses que la personne cdh mr ben
voilà
avant qu'on fasse le bouquin si jamais
on le fait je vous ai fait une adresse
mail spécifique
elle est la baisse affichant votre écran
encore une fois règles principales
anonyme
vous êtes anonyme je veux pas avoir
votre nom dans le mail etc
au pire vous vous tapez ten minutes
adresse mail qui reste dix minutes et
vous fait depuis cette adresse mail je
ne veux pas connaître votre nom si je
connais votre nom je ne lirai pas aux
brestois
ensuite il faut paquet d'éléments dans
l'histoire qu'ils font qu'on pourrait
vous identifier c'est au pire changer
quoi changer un petit peu de dix
éléments dans l'histoire qui changent
pas vraiment l'histoire jeu surtout que
soient anonymes et préparez vous à vous
faire éclater mais je vais peut-être
vous dire que vous êtes une merde faut
que vous soyez prêts à l'entendre on
préfère que tout soit clair et net
machin parce que moi j'aurais aucun
remord j'espère que cet épisode vous
aura plu
moi j'ai trouvé hyper intéressant je
trouve ça super intéressant si ce
trouble de la personnalité narcissique
on a appris des choses
en tout cas moi j'ai appris les choses
on s'ouvre la semaine prochaine pour un
autre épisode cette fois je vous parlais
de sommeil
j'espère que vous serez là nou lé pas
tous les mardis 22 heures je suis sur
twitter
et pour info ça c'est un petit peu mon
personnage switch sur tweets je suis
vraiment comme ça que vous avez la
partie que tu es etc
mais sur twitter je suis content nous
envoie ce très forte love is joe
[Musique]